[Applause]
thank you very much of course I love it
I'm in show business
but let's get this so much news I mean
if it's a week and it is a week there
has to be and there was more departures
of key people from the white house first
one this week his lead lawyer Trump's
lead lawyer on the Russia investigation
John doubt I didn't even have him in my
bracket and then from second National
Security Advisor HR McMaster he's out
and John Bolton is in remember John
Bolton yes you remember him as the
ambassador to the UN for George W Bush
so he has experience with incompetence
[Applause]
John Bolton came here we talked to him
he's another one of those Hawks you know
and the super militarist o'clock suit
never served in Vietnam the only person
by the way in military history who was
classified 4f because of his mustache
that's very rare but you know he was he
was all gung-ho John Bolton was for the
war in Iraq once now to mix it up big
time with Iran and North Korea he's what
they call an [ __ ] [ __ ]
you'll never guess where he has been
working for the last ten years Fox News
who gesture I can't
or as Trump calls it the home shopping
channel meanwhile I love this story
housing secretary ben Carson said that
he needed to spend a hundred and
thirty-one thousand dollars of taxpayer
money or maybe it's thirty one thousand
knows what it's too much money taxpayer
money for a dining room set for his
office because he said the old table
these are his words was actually
dangerous you mean compared to John
Bolton so come on let's not bury the
lead let's get to what people are really
thinking about everyone is pissed off at
Facebook right we may have to go back to
boring each other face to face this is
serious people Facebook got caught
sharing private data with people who are
using it to help elect Donald Trump and
users say this is the worst thing to
happen on Facebook since their mom sent
them a friend request this is
no there's a hashtag to lead people are
deleting their accounts share did it I
mean what's gonna happen if you don't
post 88 pictures of your toddler how
will I know that you've stopped having
sex
don't worry Mark Zuckerberg he's on it
he's gonna crack down he said oh yeah
he's gonna crack down of course he said
that before but he is so determined that
we take him seriously this time but he
promised to stop dressing like a
twelve-year-old so I I must
parenthetically say speaking of 12 year
olds you know one thing I love about
America if I have to use one word for
America I would say mature very mature
this country right I think I think
maturity okay well add to that file this
week in the maturity case the former
vice president United States and the
current president nine states threatened
to fight each other to septage canarians
Joe Biden did you see that and he said
if I was in high school now I take Trump
behind the gym and beat the hell out of
him and then Trump tweeted back Biden
would go fast down fast and hard crying
all the way
and then the vice-principal came by and
said where are you two supposed to be
[Applause]
anyway what happened with Facebook is
they led a company Cambridge analytic a
mine data from 50 million users and they
used it to build what they call
psychographic profiles of potential
Trump voters that's who were there after
so they were trying to find out all this
information they wanted to know where
they lived what kind of car they drove
what books they liked to burn all I know
is they better fix this [ __ ] quick
because Facebook is a great way to go
online and check out your old
girlfriends like like Trump does with
pornhub
yes let's see what went on in this
week's episode of restoring honor and
dignity okay this is this so much first
there is a former apprentice contestant
who says she was the victim of Trump's
unwanted sexual advances she's suing him
Playboy centerfold Karen McDougal said
they had an affair she's suing to tell
her story and of course porn star star
McDaniels have revealed a lie-detector
test this week about the time she was
[ __ ] drum and passed the test it also
came out this week that Don Jr
apparently having an affair with a print
and Apprentice contestant this must be
the breakdown of the family that
conservatives warned about if we allowed
gay marriage
[Applause]
and you know in the Don jr. case is what
allegedly his wife allegedly found out
about the affair because listen to this
so cliche checked his phone when he was
in the shower and one of the text said
we can't keep meeting like this turns
out that was from the Russians but if
you see tonight Karen McDougal the
Playboy Playmate went on Anderson Cooper
last night and talked about she had a
10-month affair had apparently sex she
said dozens of times with Donald Trump
always the same it was always the same
yes Donald you're so big Donald I love
you Donald then she would talk
[Applause]
but there was a poignant moment Karen
McDougal she said she would she said she
was sorry for what she did to the other
woman in the equation but Ivanka said
it's okay she said and someone asked
Trump about Karen McDougal did I asked
if they had unprotected sex and he said
no we had a nondisclosure agreement
but what we're all waiting for right
Sunday 60 minutes stormy Daniels is on
60 minutes I can't wait stormy says she
is not going to go into details about
sex with Donald Trump she's saving that
for another show 60 60 seconds